I was gonna thank all the little people
and then I remembered I am the little
people
that of course was the pixi who won an
Oscar for his song in 1977 and it's nice
to see him here tonight with someone
prettier than Pat McCormack was his
companion is the beauty from urban
cowboy who co-stars in the current
cannery row here are Debra Debra Winger
and Paul Williams
lucky lucky girl first john travolta
than Nick Nolte and now moi yeah The
Incredible Shrinking leading man yeah
well it looks good though don't you
little touch of Walter Pidgeon a touch
of Jodie Foster trust you appreciate the
irony and the fact that we have been
elected to to help dispense the awards
for short subjects oh yeah no I know
your music Paul and you're still short
to me no you're a giant honest business
about to be slap let's announce the
winner of the best animated short film
these are good ideas these are there are
three nominations crack produced by
Frederick Bock the creation produced by
Will Vinton and the tender tale of
Cinderella penguin produced by Janet
Roman and the winner are Adele the
winner is cracked Frederick vac producer
I thank the Academy in the name in
behalf of Leicester City Radio Canada
and all my talented chef K Mahad who
worked on this theorem on and many
others
puberty's on Norma Rae who did so
beautiful music and sound track and RFD
diabla
Jack Lew who Jean Claude Michelle Leo so
many I would like to tell how much it's
important to have all those people
around to work I will say my gratitude
to my wife given to my children my
mother and salute kbecque thank you very
much to you
there are three nominations to
live-action short films couples and
robbers Christine ostrich ur producer
aspects are ostraca Oscar well never let
it out all foreigners but they used
American Lincoln faint first winter John
n Smith producing violet Paul Kemp and
Shelley Levinson producers and the
winner the winner is your semester oh
I'm sorry
get on with it girl
the winner is violet Paul Kemp and
Shelley Levinson producers
Tony Villani of the American Film
Institute taught me that it's very easy
to make a movie and very hard to make a
good one
if violet is a good movie it is due to
him his brilliant teacher and a
wonderful critic and I'm very grateful
to him the fact that the film is a film
is due to my family of friends who
supported me and loved me and I'm very
grateful to them and I'd like to
particularly thank Harlan Ellison and
Leanne thank you
through abject terror and incredible joy
I hope I can get remember who to thank
I'd like to thank Shirley Levinson who
directed the piece and as my co-producer
Doris Betts who supplied the original
story and Susan Baskin for a wonderful
screenplay
to didi Conn an incredible cast a
hard-working and very patient crew to
all those who gave so freely of time
money and everything else and my parents
who supported me through the craziness
and the Academy for this incredible
opportunity thank you very much